hey everybody and welcome to wild ride
with stevo
this week fans of jackass rejoice
because we are talking to a jackass
legend
dave england and we laugh i believe
harder than we have ever laughed on this
podcast before
so get ready for a real treat
ladies and gentlemen dave england
yeah dude yeah i did and i don't have to
introduce you to my co-host scott
randolph we've met before right
yes scott i fed you fish for the first
time oh
and the last and the gorgeous paul
briskey is just uh
mysterious in the dark up there i'm
lurking over here dad what an honor and
thank you man i really uh
love getting to use this rv the way it
was intended where
we get like super [ __ ] and guests and
make it convenient by bringing the
studio to them
of course i told dave like we were going
to come here anyway for a double date
like hang out with our girls and camp
out on dave's dope
this is your idea of a double date here
dude my girl set it up with dave's girl
we're gonna double date and so i'm like
yo dave dude when we come can we
[ __ ] do a podcast with you like yeah
i'm an [ __ ]
so what do you want to do yeah what are
you guys doing after the podcast you
guys have dinner planned
uh i think we would probably build a big
bonfire on your property
we could i love it and we get to to make
it worse we get here and dave's like yo
dude i'm
can we do this tomorrow i'm covered in
poison oak and i'm like i don't know
dave dude the guys came up like
that i went camping this weekend i have
it in my eyes
my arms on my legs how do you get that
on on my dick
on my ball wow how do you get it on you
i don't know i don't know because it's
everywhere i think it was all my pants
maybe and then uh
in the middle of night i took off i
kicked my pants off because it was hot
and then they were just in the bed
like intermingling with my legs or
something i don't know how do you know
you have it
like because i have like giant rashes
all over me that itch like crazy
wow i can't sleep i haven't slept the
last two nights i slept but not
like i want to sleep wow man i heard a
story one time where these kids threw
poison oak on a campfire and everybody
yeah yeah it's really bad if you burn it
wow dude i had no idea that poison oak
was so gnarly and it's everywhere around
here too
really is there a jackass stunt with
poison oak
yeah wouldn't you just ignored it yeah
no it's right it lasts for like a week
yeah what would happen if you like
chopped it up and snorted it
all bad last time i did that it was
it was a long week dude let me say that
out of
everybody on jackass i genuinely think
that you're the most [ __ ]
creative guy i i agree wholeheartedly
i think so too yeah like i mean like in
what ways
let's look back at your instagram for
one when you first started instagram i
was like jesus dude
yeah you're just doing some pretty
creative stuff with like skateboarding
and
like little videos that you did bro i
mean you could tell a dave england idea
from the beginning of jackass because it
was like
you got a [ __ ] a big like cylinder
rolling downhill while he's
skateboarding inside it like all of this
like
maybe a bad example give us uh some of
your early greatest hits
flicking the door stopper was just like
that's pure genius right there
you're a genius yeah just a [ __ ]
creative guy man
who was uh urban kayaking your idea yep
right yeah and if anybody doesn't know i
think it's
your most uh like iconic bit
would that be taking a [ __ ] in the
toilet at the hardware store
yeah that would be my most iconic
written by whitey mcconaughey
whitey wrote that how crazy is that nice
dude who's whitey mcconaughey
he's a snowboard guy yeah a snowboard uh
videographer
okay cinematographer i think he's
cinnamon or sugar or something
photographer
exactly that's how creative he is it
wasn't the the [ __ ] at the hardware
store wasn't it like you showed up the
first day but no
pants on the way there or something no
well there was too many
customers in there to clear them all so
they're like wait wait wait i guess it
was just a really busy day at the
hardware store and i'd already had this
hot sauce that
like like it's a ticking time bomb in me
so they're like hold on hold on three
hours went by
and we're in the van waiting outside and
it's like raining and wet and
and then tremaine starts you know
jabbing me in the ribs i'm like
seriously dude i'm not joking i'm going
to [ __ ] my pants and
so the heater blasting is all like moist
and humid you're from the rain and then
when that [ __ ] like three people puked
out of the van load of people in there
there was a there was a bit
there wasn't a lot of stuff that we
filmed where it's like
you know yo we can't show this you know
like mtv just shoots it down like
we will not show this i had like where i
got the i got branded a heart over my
heart like they let us film it but then
they were like no
there's no [ __ ] way we can chill and
that never got shown oh really very
little things
what i ever got what did we see of you
then that you got branded yeah because
i've seen that footage
uh it came out like on like something
like afternoon it was never allowed on
tv
never allowed on tv but uh the
the [ __ ] uh the one that dave had
which wasn't allowed on and ultimately
it did end up getting on
but it was like uh in the ball and it
was it was fake poo
i know the idea is the poo diaper diaper
yeah
he just took a [ __ ] chocolate pudding
put it in a diaper and stashed it in a
trash can
like where there's a bunch of people and
then i asked them for change you know i
was like
doesn't take much for me to look like a
homeless guy so i was looking like a
homeless guy like oh do you have any
change no one would give it to me so i i
dug in the trash so hungry i dig in the
trash and there's a plant we planted a
diaper in there with you know
pudding and i ate it out of the diaper
so hungry
[Applause]
in the hardware store oh yeah that was
during our team that was like the
last few uh episodes of our tv show
before that movie
okay what's your infatuation with
[ __ ] right no wait but with that
that wasn't shitty it was just pudding
right but then mtv we filmed it and it
turned out really funny and then mtv's
like there's no way we're putting that
on tv it's too gross just
it's just pudding you know anyway so so
knoxville from what i understood i could
have this wrong
but he said i quit if you don't put that
on tv so they're like okay okay
you put it on and then he goes then
after he goes i quit anyway
i think that the one that he said he
would quit was like it was his cousin or
something and his cousin they had
footage of his cousin where it's like
you know i'm gonna fart or something and
it was the act it's called the
accidental poop
like uh some nervous nephew some family
member and he goes to
to fart and like a poop comes out
and i think knoxville really went to war
to get that yeah did it make it on tv i
don't remember that
because mtv won't allow [ __ ] at all
right or paramount or anybody won't
allow [ __ ]
because dog [ __ ] yeah but no but like
dog [ __ ] right but like but then in the
movies
chris rabbit chris rapp was allowed to
[ __ ] like run full speed yeah kind of
[ __ ] right yeah
yeah i don't know where they draw the
line yeah he wait what he ran full speed
and took a shot
based on a george carlin joke yeah yeah
where did that air um on the tv show we
just saw that on a cky video though and
it wasn't until it never got off
i don't know i definitely yeah i don't
know if it was yeah i don't know if i
made it but i thought it did
i think it did i swear i think it did
but um then once we hit the movies then
it was like
like i've taken a [ __ ] in every movie
we've made so far like a real [ __ ] this
real [ __ ]
everybody we didn't fake it yeah you've
taken a [ __ ] and everything
well my question is wendy it was real
when and how
like when did you become the [ __ ] guy
was it was it high school
what was it called you're sort of known
for [ __ ] like when did that
i remember like there was like a field
behind my neighborhood
where all the kids were playing and
nobody wanted to play with me ever and i
remember
back then when i when i was a kid the
gatorade bottles were glass
it's like really big mouth so i [ __ ] in
the glass gatorade bottle and threw it
on a stump
in the backfield there with all the kids
there and the glass went everywhere and
the [ __ ] smashed on the stump and then
from then on out like i was cool all
right wow
so then when you got jackass you're like
oh [ __ ] because that that'll make me
cool here that
they're just like yeah for me what i i
was surprised they're like you can just
[ __ ] whatever but yeah
like you can just seem like a big deal
yeah i could [ __ ] in front of someone
but
way before i could pee in front of them
like easily yeah
and originally it was chris pontius who
was the [ __ ] guy
he did the poocano right right because
oh yeah yeah the big brother video he
did it and i've always yeah so he did
the first volcano i think
dave carney wrote it and then chris
pawnees did it but like they did it all
wrong he like laid down and the poop
went sideways it didn't turn out right
and ever since then that was like
mid-90s and that was wrong i thought
that was [ __ ] it was still awesome
amazing if you're gonna call it pocano
it needs to be looking right
straight up no yeah let me rephrase that
before i get beat up by chris
no no no no it's fine and i mean if
anything that i thought
it was it was just that you saw that it
was an enema like
the water came out and then the you know
yeah well then well
i was all ready to do mine so i'm i've
got my legs over this way
and my butt up this way and i'm like
okay guys i'm ready to go i'd
carefully plan like for one month i
didn't eat i didn't drink any caffeine
and then to that day i ate as much as i
could and drank two giant red bulls
and so i'm laying up there ready to go
and they're like one more thing and
you know they got that whole train set
thing over this was for jackass three
days
three years was part of it and so i'm
all ready to go and they didn't tell me
they had
this plan then pontius comes up with an
enema he's like
like no chris i'm good i'm good
seriously dude don't put that in me was
pretty rough
but whatever he's my friend he's allowed
to do that if he thinks it's necessary
and he did it so if you watch it you can
see that i like kind of just shut the
water out separately because i can
i can keep penetrating my apartment you
can get rid of that
you'll see it like some water goes out
and then all this [ __ ] comes out wait so
you can you have like
can you fart on command no but you can
[ __ ] right now if we wanted you to
yeah do you want me to so did you did
you have the opening scene for one of
the jackass movies where you [ __ ] on the
toilet
like the little dollhouse toilet yeah
that was a great one yeah
so that one so so uh i did the fire hose
rodeo in
part two so and then i i slammed my ass
super bad
and went to the hospital they gave me
some painkillers so i took them
and then the next day they're like let's
do this your idea with a little toilet
we have the whole thing set up
and i'm like guys like the pain pills i
can't take a [ __ ] and so
so they're like let's try it anyways so
you know everyone's all the cameras are
me i'm trying as hard as i can
and and you know i don't know like pain
pills i think it's pretty
much everybody they constipated like
even though i'm a professional [ __ ]
come on i'm human
this is what happened so i want this
footage by the way i gotta find this
i took a [ __ ] that was proportional to
the little toilet
it was like the right size for the
toilet and they're like oh forget it and
they went to throw it away i'm like ah
i grabbed it i'm like i'll clean it out
and we'll let's i'll hang on to this and
i'll bring it
and we'll film it so like i kept it with
me and then
we were at knoxville's house one day i'm
like hey can we do this and they're like
let's do it
how big of a deal is that to get like
the first shot of a movie
like well you can cause the first
one you
you want to start filming a jackass
movie like
with something that you're pretty sure
is gonna work
so that like your first shoot is like
gives you like
a good high morale to start off like on
a good vibe you don't want to like shoot
something that might work
as the first thing you want to come out
of the gates so for the second movie
i don't remember what the first one was
but the second movie the first shoot was
the puppet show where pontius put his
dick in the thing and got bit by a snake
like there was no way that wasn't gonna
work yeah and then on the third movie
it was uh fart darts
you met that guy at the show right yeah
that was another good start
he didn't have a butthole uh he was born
without a butthole
yeah i remember like we we shot the uh
we shot the [ __ ]
fart dart scene and and we're all
hanging out on the set afterwards like
everything was great i'm standing there
with knoxville
while will the farter was telling us
like how he was born without a butthole
he's like i think he prefaces it by
don't tell anyone i told you this
but i was born
yeah i know i don't think that was the
case at all i think
uh
he's like please don't tell anybody this
went down like that
none of this will air oh my god but
we we have his info right oh here's one
for will departure
nice that's nice dude that was the first
audible fart i think on the show oh wow
about it right i've never heard of it
yeah next time you got to stand up and
put your butt in the mic
now speaking about [ __ ] okay there
was a dave england moment
that i wasn't there for but it happened
in europe
whoa whoa whoa i need everybody to take
a deep breath
because you are about to find yourself
laughing
maybe harder than you've ever laughed
while listening to a podcast
that is my prediction it is also my
prediction
that if you sell stuff online in any
capacity
on amazon on etsy on your own website on
through any channel that you're going to
do a lot
better business if you use shipstation
you know how i'm always talking about
like we've got the warehouse the
fulfillment center
the whole secret to it is ship station
every single order is just
automated all the different sales
channels are just funneled into one easy
interface
and you can control it from anywhere
even on your cell phone
okay plus it gives you access to like
the
best discount rates which used to be
reserved for fortune 500 companies so
yeah
if you're not selling stuff you're
blowing it if you are selling stuff
get ready to sell a lot more efficiently
a lot more easily and for a lot less
money
okay and i'm going to give you a 60-day
risk-free trial that's 60 days of
absolutely hassle-free stress-free
shipping
and you don't have to pay anything okay
so to get this deal
you're going to go to shipstation.com
and
at the top of the page you're going to
click the microphone
icon type in the promo code stevo and
you're off to the races sign up
and just start selling stuff it's time
to make
ship happen now one more time
shipstation.com top of the page click
the microphone type in the promo code
stevo
and start selling now get ready to laugh
right what's that was it you're [ __ ]
you said paris in paris
romantic paris this is a kid we did the
gumball rally right and the gumball
rally was a special jackass episode with
me pontius and
knoxville and we went like racing
through 10 different countries in a big
loop through europe with all these crazy
millionaires
it's all kinds of fun uh when we got
back to england where we started
i was done and then they continued on to
shoot in like amsterdam and paris like
uh
all these different places and dave
england was there for
all that filming but if i if i've got
the story right you guys are staying in
a hotel in paris
tremaine's out like drinking and you
think it's funny that
like you're gonna take a [ __ ] and smear
your own [ __ ] all over
tremaine's hotel door handle we were
there to work
and he flew his fiancee now wife laura
in
and they went out on a romantic date and
i thought that was total [ __ ]
so so we were all always there
the rest of us are like what can we do
about this and i think it was me and bam
that
went in cahoots on this and just were
like okay
someone needs to take a [ __ ] i don't
think bam was no he was yeah he was
there for sure
yeah he was definitely there was that
yeah and then and then so
anyways long story short i took a [ __ ]
rubbed it all over his
uh tremaine's hotel door room and then
when they got we waited
on the outside yeah on the outside of
his hotel door room so when he gets back
from the date they get back they're
going to go back to the hotel
and we're watching from around the
corner he just fully just
full squeeze turns yeah yeah we had we
had something like i don't
maybe not a very good camera but yeah
and not very good angles
so tremaine was like okay you got me
good but the thing was that
at that point then i went out drinking
and back then we always shared hotel
rooms we weren't like baller status yet
where we got our own hotel room yeah i
was sharing
my hotel room with gooch one of the
producers and so tremendous like god
dave england's such a dumb ass schmuck
because i'm with gooch who's got a key
to dave england's room
so gooch lets tremaine into dave
england's room
and and uh so tremaine goes in there
he's probably all drunk too
dave's got his suitcase opened up and
tremaine just [ __ ]
pulls out his dick and just pisses into
dave england
pisses on everything in his suitcase and
and that was a step too far for dave
england
um okay so i don't know because you had
bought a gift yeah from my
like i had my first uh kid
my daughter was on the way like no like
she wasn't born yet but i bought her a
stuffed animal
i don't know it was stupid i looked like
yeah ruby i bought ruby this stuffed
bunny i remember i put it in there it
was just covered in tremaine's piss
and that i don't know that i guess it
was just the whole thing like all my
stuff was covered in piss
and i was drunk and our next stop was
amsterdam the next morning oh
dude we're going straight to amsterdam
so i'm like well [ __ ] that i called the
hotel
it was dirty during spring break
i flew back home in the middle of the
night and canceled everybody's [ __ ] for
their like next
like real dick
in my bag of my daughter's stuffed
animal that's why
[ __ ] dude in here dude i forgot about
all that dude
you [ __ ] on his door handle a door
handle
you wash your hand watch it leave the
door handle another teddy bear
or like wash your clothes dude we came
out here to work man
and neither are you
yeah when did they learn what happened
like um
yeah well they they woke up the next day
they went to the airport to get their
flight they're like
you canceled the flight and then they're
like they got somehow got another flight
got to the
to amsterdam at during spring break and
they're like you don't have a hotel room
so they got pretty mad at me didn't you
get fired
i was like [ __ ] i [ __ ] canceled
all your [ __ ]
that's funny dude was that so so was
that darth mode
can we talk about darkness that was
borderline darf that's a little too
organized for darth vader
that was that was the creation
together like that that was like yeah
that was just
that was tipsy yeah you wanted an
example of dave's creativity
so can we explain who darth is i just if
i drink
too much it's just england's alter ego
do you remember who you do you remember
when you're darf
i always usually wake up in the morning
i'm like hey everybody how's it going
and they're like how dare you show your
face here
like what what what what then they
started [ __ ]
listing [ __ ] off like this like you did
this this this
there wasn't enough hours to do that
like how was i that busy
very busy dude yeah dave england gets
drunk to the point where he becomes his
alter ego
darf and like nothing good happens
yeah i don't do it much cause i remember
i remember was it was a 2.5 when
tremaine was talking about how
you know darf came out and then the next
day they had you like jumping off of a
hor or
yeah yeah yeah so was that before the
shots off the horse first three that was
three three
yeah that was three so that was so that
was way yeah
yeah that was like early in three and
then dave was like uh
like i didn't drink for the rest of that
whole movie and then for another three
years
like three years three years what was
that what was a terrible darf
uh episode like was it tremaine's
wedding or bam's wedding
oh bam's wedding and he went through the
hotel just breaking everything i broke a
lot of stuff i guess that's what i was
told
april was so disappointed that was the
worst part for me is april's
disappointment
where was this in and so you can have
the hotel somewhere yeah maybe
philadelphia or something
what what do you drink that makes you
turn into darf uh alcohol of any sort
but you don't know whiskey or tequila
really does the trick
tequila does the trick any alcohol that
gets you can like quickly like
like the beer's taking me so long to
drink finally i'm like ah foue i give up
yeah but that the hard outcome you're
like this is the wow it's going down
easier and easier and easier wow i don't
know
yeah nothing nothing to be proud of
that's for sure
but it's made some people laugh people
seem to laugh when they tell the stories
but at the time nobody's laughing
yeah dude i'm so [ __ ] good man
he wakes up no idea that anything was
wrong how dare you
i mean you must have had mornings like
that too steve right where you're like
yeah what's your alter ego
i mean i i had the time
when uh we were in russia and i got so
[ __ ] that we got so wasted on vodka
and part of the night like was me
kissing pontius on the dick you don't
remember that no i do remember that
and then i suppose like uh i don't
remember anything
maybe later but the next morning i came
out of this little
bungalow cottage thing and there's
he looks at me just with disgust
absolute [ __ ] disgust he says
do you know what you did last night and
all of a sudden my heart just [ __ ]
stops and i'm like
oh my god i'm about to hear like i just
did something so [ __ ] terrible oh no
oh no
what is it what is it he goes you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he was so mad at me for kissing the dick
that's so funny dude
but you do you and i said oh dude is
that all sweet
yeah [ __ ] man that's so good i mean were
you a blackout drinker or did you just
do
too much cocaine to where you were just
up yeah
i didn't black out too much you ever
wake up in jail or like you knew you're
going to jail oh
i thought dude what a creepy thought i
don't think i've always known i was
going to jail
have you ever been to jail i had no idea
that dave had been to jail so many times
you know what happens when you go to
jail you want to watch out for your
butthole
do you have a butthole well i got
something for it
it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and it is delicious a lot
of people wonder look
why would you call it that well in my
view it's so delicious
that you're just gonna consume enough of
it your butthole's not only gonna find
out about it oh it is kind of like it
and you can get it on amazon you know
when
people are buying this stuff like we go
up the rankings of hot sauce on amazon
we've been up to number
three man maybe we can get to number one
if you if all of you go on to amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
please do it now because that would sure
mean a lot to me
now let's hear about dave going to jail
i've been to jail
five times in three countries wow dude
nice do you have any mug shots
probably i don't really seek them out
what what countries
uh united states new zealand
and japan don't go to jail in japan oh
yeah oh what's that
windows what were you in in japan for
oh i guess i stole a bike in the middle
of night was that dark we went with that
when we were there
the movie i was lost and i couldn't find
anyone it was a
broken down bike like nobody wanted it
was already a discarded bike i swear
like i don't go around stealing bikes
i was lost trying to find my hotel and
like finally i'm like i'm just gonna
grab this bike and it didn't have a
light
i don't go around stealing bikes i find
them yeah
so then they're like they're like they
come they're like you know i guess you
have some kind of
papers or something for your bike there
i don't know what they wanted but i
didn't have it i you know it's a
communication
so they got a translator and then then
they're like you stole the bike
and then uh and then so they didn't know
what to do they held me there overnight
and the next day they're like
where did you get this bike i'm like i
don't know i don't know they're like
we're gonna drive you around until you
find it i'm like okay
and they drove me around like oh look
right there like finally i just made up
a spot i was like that's where exactly
where it was they're like
sure i'm like right there right against
that railing that wasn't when we were
there
no this is for snowboarding i used to go
there all the time in the 90s what's the
jail
like in japan no windows just just
dark dark dark like they're just opening
the door and checking you every now and
then like give you sushi
no i don't know they gave me some food i
didn't eat it i don't know what it was
to need it i was just it was scary i
thought it'd be in there forever
really how long were you there for this
friend yep from the
like midnight till like midday the next
day and then what'd you do in new
zealand
uh i i bought a little car
this little t it was like a mini but the
front of it looked like a rolls royce
it's called a land crab a wolseley
that's cool and that
so like i bought it and then then like i
rented this little place on this hill
and like two miles down the hill was the
bar and so i took two shots of whiskey
got in a little car drove down the hill
then i was like looking at it i was like
wow i love this little car and this cop
comes by he's like is that your little
car i'm like yeah
he's like do you just drive down that
hill like yeah he's like breathe into
this
really and he gave me he gave me they
call it a instead of a dui they call it
a d a dickey a dic a drunk in control
a wow a drunk drunk in charge i think
he's drunk that sounds right
a drunken charge of a vehicle or
something and then so i had to go to
court and it was a 500
fine and i lost my license in new
zealand for six months
i just kept driving well how long you're
in new zealand for
like four or five months and that was
for snowboarding too
yeah for because they have opposite
seasons is this all pre
yeah like jackass started from a
skateboarding magazine called big
brother
and like big brother had like if i'm if
i'm right like sort of a
sister like magazine which was devoted
to snowboarding called blunt
yeah ken block had started it the guy
started dc and you know he's the race
car driver now
he started uh blunt magazine which ended
up because
then steve rob steve rocco you know he
was the owner of big brother he
bought blunt from ken block after like
five or six
uh um
episodes i just kind of want to say was
that larry flint publishing no no
then so then rocco bought the mag so he
had both mags then he sold
both mags to larry flint oh i didn't
know blunt was purchased by larry
no okay you're not gonna believe this
they wanted the snowboard magazine more
than they wanted the skateboard magazine
wow
like rock was like you gotta take that
just like you gotta tell me that doesn't
add up because it was the kids issue of
big brother with sheckler
that uh it's caused all the controversy
that made larry flint want to buy a big
brother you could say that but
they saw but their magazines they had
like hot boat magazine all these other
magazines
and they snowboarding was getting really
big right then and they're like they
want they thought it was going to be
this
you know like legit snowboard magazine
we were like it was like the
snowboard version of big brother instead
and they didn't like that at all
it's crazy because i thought that larry
flint published like 27
porno magazines and one skateboard
magazine for kids i never know
so many magazines so many just
mainstream stuff you would never
think did did he own all the [ __ ] that
was in that building because i remember
like
when i went to the the brazilian
consulates in there like when i had to
go
there yeah that thing's huge building
well that's what they're saying like he
would recruit girls that would come in
from brazil like to get their visas or
vice versa and he'd be like yeah come
you know right
but i was i was at the office next door
to big brother so i would just you know
help them out with the videos and stuff
like do little skits in them and then uh
all of a sudden
you know tremaine's like oh we're gonna
try to make a tv show you want to be
involved i'm like hell yeah
yeah so what what did you do at the the
blunt magazine
i was there he snowboarded and that's
how he lost one of his balls
yeah well i was a pro snowboarder in the
early part of the 90s and then uh
and then i ended up writing stories and
taking a bunch of photos and
and then ended up being the the editor
for blunt so the editor that means
you're like running the magazine yeah
right you were like jeff tremaine dave
carney
the funny part is yeah i was more like
carney because tremaine was the
art director of big brother magazine it
wasn't
actually and then when rocco sold it to
larry flint then truman
sort of became editor-in-chief
in our magazine anytime like the people
upstairs wanted to talk to us like you
know
the flint people we're like jeff will
you go talk to them
because we were like scared of them we
didn't know how to talk their language
we're like i don't know those [ __ ]
want to talk to us
he's like all right all right he'd go
deal with him for us tell us about
losing your ball
uh in 1991 he's got one of you but
you yeah okay in 1997 i was snowboarding
in new zealand and i
i overshot a jump i did a frontside 360
and which you're like
the last one that you're blind of and so
like i came around and like just
landed really flat and and got a double
hernia that's where your
gut wall opens up on both sides and or
your stomach wall opens up and lets some
of your guts through
and they get squeezed wow and you can
kind of like push it back in there but
it just keeps popping out and it's like
this
horrible like the blood flow gets taken
away or something so like i'm like ah
they're like you need to go to the
hospital i'm just gonna fly home and do
it
so i should have went to the hospital
there because i didn't know but my nut
cord was
strangulated in there too so i came back
here got the surgery wake up
and there's this horrible stinging
sensation like what the hell and they're
like oh sorry we had to
take one of your testicles out they just
told you well yeah i was out for the
surgery i'm like wake up like what where
is it
i want it and they're like so like you
signed uh you know we can throw all
medical waste away
that's not what i would have done i'm
like it's not medical waste this is my
ball
like give it back i want to put it in a
jar formaldehyde and put it on my
my mantel or something like that people
say you only got one ball
i got two there's the other one right
there i
actually oh then so anyways yeah then
they said i couldn't have babies but i
had four so [ __ ]
doctors never listen to what a doctor
says about yeah they told me so many
[ __ ] up [ __ ] over the years
the uniballer is the most prolific child
bearer or but this is the other idea the
other day like
like i should have got that ball
cremated and then made into an egg timer
as the sand you know yeah yeah i kind of
want when i die why i should just want
to do a giant sand timer oh that'd be
cool
yeah do people do that that's really i
don't think i don't think ashes work
like sand
okay i don't care i still want to be
heavy there's a broken sand
what does that mean what does that feel
like there's a ball like does it feel
like getting kicked in the nuts
have you ever heard of when people get
an arm take off they get ghost limb
they feel like the limb still there yeah
phantom limb yeah phantomlin
i felt like that i would be like i swear
it would be there like what what
it's just not there but it feels like
it's there it hangs right in the middle
really no this one's still waiting it's
still hanging from that body yeah
you're right now my right spoon
i'm like you can move into the middle
it's like no no he's coming back is
there like a little bit of
sack on the missing side no it's kind of
just or it's just like
it's can't be really high i'll tell you
that oh yeah when it gets cold
what happens the other one tries to
crawl back inside and what happens to
you
i gotta show you this tattoo design i
came up with oh wow
the extra testicle i like that yeah
that's really good well it looks like
he has a weird hairdo i like it
reaction dude i think this is the
funniest [ __ ] thing that i've ever
come up with
yeah if it was even two it would be
extra
yeah do you have any tattoos that you
want to come up with
some tattoos i don't want to come up
like a creative idea for a tattoo i'm
not really
into tattoos you don't have any tattoos
i have two tattoos with one over the
other
really yeah it's like a bear a pig but i
don't even care about it i don't care
about tattoos i just there's not even
on my radar oh right
i'm so obviously like for the people
watching you're missing a tooth
yeah and you just rock it well do you
like do you like not having
at first it was kind of a cool novelty
but now i'm over it and then i was about
to get a dental implant i had the little
receding end in there i was just about
to get it
and then they're they're like they've
been this one's been on shaky ground
because i got smashed in the face
surface surfboard hit me and then so it
didn't just hit that one and hit a lot
of them this one
is dead too and maybe some of the others
too i'm hoping not but
this one has to be removed so they can't
put the this one in until they pull this
one out
but then i'll have two missing like i
got two yeah then i've seen you like
that i'm like
two missing that looks like you're
missing
[Laughter]
why don't you get one of these flipper
things i have the flipper and i hate it
like i can't
i just can't have that in my mouth i
can't like i can't i can't deal with
that thing and
i kind of dig it man i don't know i
don't i'm like the whole time you should
get fitted for another one i think that
like sometimes
like uh you got one that's not fitted
it fits perfectly i can't get it out
either the dennis me his dentist tool
to go home with he's like i don't know
you got to use this oops
yeah so uh but yeah eventually i'll get
i'll get my teeth fixed jeff tremaine
the director of jackass says
don't ever fix it oh yeah i'm not
listening to him
he's he's a bad guy yeah he peed on your
bunny
don't forget to cancel him he cancels
his mortgage yeah
nobody pees on my butt i so forgot about
the canceling the flights dude that's so
hardcore
can i ask you about uh jackass injuries
because i remember when we were
when we were in ohio or we were
somewhere i think in phoenix that like
you got to go to the chiropractor
because you're like dude
my neck is so [ __ ] up in 2010
when we did jackass three i just kept
getting neck injuries that whole movie
like bam kicked me
yeah and then that [ __ ] up and then
like we
we did this thing in this hallway with a
boogie board and all these balls and i
caught my head on one of the doorways
and hurt my neck really bad
and then uh and then i that slingshotted
me into that swimming pool and one time
i just went headfirst in the swimming
pool and cranked my neck
so like from 2010 to 2015
my neck hurts so goddamn bad and i did
everything i could and finally i got a
surgery
that's why did you get uh did you get
the
paramount to pay for the neck surgery no
i don't know how to do that
[Laughter]
yeah they like they fuse your discs
together damn
i saw a pretty goddamn good mobility and
i couldn't sleep it was the problem and
i can sleep for the most part
right now for the poison [ __ ] dying
it's all my [ __ ] eyes
really damn i remember when uh we had
like the
the jackass takeover like uh we were
doing the jackass world this was right
before
i got sober so i was at my absolute
worst oh yeah in new york i remember
that yeah i was at my house
you were at your worst that was an
understatement
yeah and and my yeah my worst is is
something else because
my best isn't that great but you decided
you could only walk on money do you
remember that
but then there's another guy right
behind me cleaning it because they
didn't have enough to like keep going
and then
clean that money and then throw now
they're going to throw more money it was
like a cycle
like uh coming to america where they're
walking on rose petals
but with money what's that [ __ ] dance
you had to be one kind of money it was
like ones and [ __ ]
oh my god i don't remember that but now
that you remind me yeah
oh my god right that's great but there
was a shoot that was going on when we
were in new york for that time because
we were trying to film all these bits
for uh
jackass world they thought that this is
going to be great we're going to have a
website that's going to
you know and like there's a winch on
like an ice skating thing
oh yeah that [ __ ] me up you got you
got pretty hurt on that yeah they had
those fat suits
you know like fat [ __ ] or whatever
suits so like you're supposed to be
you know there's nothing bad no harm can
come your way when you're wearing that a
bunch of
bubble wrap so uh it was like this
high-speed
pulling wench thing and and you go off a
launch ramp and then
it was like a pyramid of trash cans yeah
and the idea i think would be
you know i basically just like let
everything go to [ __ ]
when you hit the trash cans but for some
reason i'm like i'm gonna land it
i [ __ ] landed on the ice and my one
leg just slipped out and just
[ __ ] blew out my knee really bad damn
did you have knee surgery from that
no i just did rehab it was just my mcl
not my acl
huh you can rehab mcl i remember
considering that
like uh part of like a jackass curse
where if something's been done and then
you just go and reshoot the same thing
that that's when like terrible injuries
happen and for some reason i thought
that that
ice rink thing was a redo and maybe it
was
i just showed it it wasn't my idea i was
like okay
it looked funny it was fun and then it
hurt when when carney
it was carny like uh was
right and so he was jumping over trash
cans it was on an ice skating rink and
he's crashing into church
on the skin board though but yeah yeah
the track it did have a lot of
similarities with that you're right yeah
i didn't even think of that ever
because i had something i did on my own
where 50 cent
threw me down a bunch of concrete stairs
on the bell hop cart
and i somehow miraculously got away with
it he did it three times in a row and i
was fine
and and tremaine loved that footage so
they got me to redo it
and it was redoing it for jackass number
two i had the worst injury
with john waters with john john waters
the director of like pink flamingos and
hairspray and a bunch of other awesome
movies anyways he
he's like just like kind of smaller like
really nice guy but
hilarious he was cracking us up it's
just so funny all day we're like this
guy's the best
and then he pushes they're both in like
bellhop outfits connie has
pushed it for some reason i don't think
i thought he pushed it i did okay
i think that was all i did he would just
give it a little push and he'd fall down
and then and he had to
be taken away in an ambulance and john
water's just like oh my god what have i
done
he was like so bummed he was dead taking
away an ambulance he was devastated
after that
i i bet dude like i i [ __ ] like
landed on the bell hop cart but somehow
like didn't even look like anything and
the footage was [ __ ]
in the credits of the movie yeah it
didn't look bad when it happened but it
didn't look bad
you [ __ ] that's your lower back did
you break any bones i don't know
dude i can't remember i i forget what
they said if there was like
any kind of little fracture all i know
is i was out of commission dude and i
was [ __ ] well
i wasn't in like so much footage for
that for that second movie
yeah so then when when tremaine came to
me about the fish hook and he was like
hey man like
would you put the hook through your face
again on another day
so we can get more shark footage and and
i was like dude i gotta
like i'm light on footage man i need
yeah i'll do it
because the first time i put the hook
through my face there was me and pontius
and some like
official like body piercer guy who was
like
doing the face piercing and tremaine
hated that he was like it's like here's
his body because he's like who is this
guy he's like
can we do it again where it's just
pontius putting the hook through your
face
you know and like and it would also
really help us if we do it go out again
we can get more sharks
i was in south africa or the gulf uh
that was in the the goal of the gulf of
mexico
off louisiana and so i was like yeah
[ __ ] yeah put the hook through my face
again
the second time and uh and and that was
the second day when the mako went from
my foot and i kicked the makeover
and i was so lucky because
i was i was off [ __ ] kicking a maker
shark in the face
while we had split cruise and you guys
were doing the riot test
i don't think and that was like you're
like most like
i went back and i won't i can't be a
part of it i would have been with you
yeah it was horrible they did it on a
dummy first and i was and they're like
it won't draw blood it won't break the
skin
and i thought i hit that dummy they were
lying they were lying like tore it apart
yeah
i remember ryan came up to me after he's
like you're so smart to not do that he
was so bummed he's like i wish i did not
do that
damn yeah who ended up doing it was
yeah like done in knoxville dave tapped
out and said he wouldn't do it
bam cried after right it was cry worthy
yeah
it's like it's to make prisoners not
want to leave the you know like riot
like when they
just blast you with thousands of these
little balls right
i wouldn't it does it's a spirit breaker
there's a spirit breaker
yes i i would not have done well with
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh one thing that comes to mind that you
did that was just
i don't know how gnarly it was but it
looked crazy when you showed up at
knoxville's place
and the airbag like blasted yeah that
was a crazy one because it was my day
off
and i had been bugging knoxville for a
long time
back when ipods and you're like it's
just all does this whole music and you
can go like
someone else's computer and just load
all their music onto it so he has so
much awesome music i'm like
just kept bugging him and bugging him
you know i gotta get all your stuff on
my ipod and he's like yeah we'll get
around to it one day just calls me up on
my day off hey
you want to get all that music i'm like
yeah come on over
oh my god so like if you watch it again
you'll see like it's in my hand
just goes flying into the street and
broke oh my god
you didn't get the music no i did not
get the music i got [ __ ]
knocked in there i got yeah what it was
was the
like the intercom you push the button
you push the button and there's like a
little camera so you're like look
putting your face right there to be on
camera and it comes blasting at that an
airbag high speed airbag around that
thing knocked me
on the same exact day he tells dave
england you want to get
all the music he tells me he goes hey
dude
can you dress up as a clown and come
over to my house and like [ __ ] yeah
so i put on full clown makeup like the
whole deal had to go over and they just
didn't get a good shot
oh but did you get hit with that same
thing i did like i think it was just
wasn't as like direct of a hit
you know like but
i didn't suspect anything
yeah and it was that night too that's
why i went uh when i stripped bam naked
in my apartment was that same night i
was in clown makeup from that same thing
oh wow
in that shot of me uh stripping bam yeah
yeah where was that footage of you
stripping bam on your youtube now right
we we finally we finally found a home
for it
in the uh my best naked stunts
was that in your apartment where you
owned four apartments yeah
in the building where i was renting for
a park why didn't you just get a house
like what's your thought like you're
like i got an apartment and then you
wanted to before
compartmentalized like one would party
one was skate
one was business and the other one was
more like your well then the other one
was for my
assistant did you ever go over there oh
yeah all the time
do you remember anyone over there any
fun times over there lots of fun times
it's great it's all about fun times it's
like why would it not be fun
we had a full skate park in one of them
that was awesome and then just
yeah like bong hits and beer and
whippets and [ __ ] everywhere
video games and just like yeah
weird people coming over so did you did
you rent those all at once or were you
did you get one and you're like we
should get another one
i got i kept that adding yeah i remember
like
i thought it was crazy we had two and
then three like four
yeah i like that one time you like
bashed in the wall to your neighbors
oh yeah well just the people that were
over there happened just imagine if
you're the other guy
i know dude that must have been crazy
yeah
was that your only neighbor that ever
complained like being next to the skate
park would have been
terrible i would think well next to the
skatepark was like some russian hookers
they had like a little prostitution deal
going on so they weren't like trying to
come they were looking for some noise
coverage anyway
right and like the other the other side
of the skate park apartment had like a
stairwell
and underneath was the parking garage so
that one was like pretty well situated
nice yeah i feel like i would want to be
next to the the whip it's one because
you'd probably
you're just doing this i'm not making
much noise
you know well the whip-it one it was a
problem like
uh and i did get complaints from the
family
it was just this like foreign family and
the dad would come over
like in his boxer shorts and he had his
family and he was like
my family's trying to sleep and the
walls are shaking
please i actually went back to that
uh to the like early in sobriety i went
back
to the building and they said hey you
know like i had this family next to me
and like
i just want to like you know pay a month
to their rent just just because
and but they had already moved out did
you ever find them
i did not man too bad you can't reach
out to him
i would love to yeah that whole
if you're watching this like
you just want to go revisit it and make
things right yeah well dude now we're
going to have live
oh dude i was a family it was the family
dude i've had that experience do you
remember who they are though
no no no i only remember in the middle
of the night i'm all [ __ ] up the guys
in his boxer shorts begging me like to
make the walls stop
shaking oh my god dude
it was really bad wow yeah dude so
uh can we promote anything for you and i
think the answer is no so can we set up
why not because no i don't got anything
do you have anything going on
no you're not i mean when i didn't mean
that i didn't mean that to sound shitty
no it's not shitty it's just i i'm
pretty happy with how it's
dude i think you're i think you're a
considerably more healthy person than i
am
you know like i'm actually what well
dude you've got these kids and your kids
are [ __ ] running around like
crazy like where anybody would lose
their [ __ ] mind with the
the chaos of your kids running around
yeah you seem like a good dad
you see you're completely unfazed
sometimes oh i'm pretty faithful
i mean do you ever get mad at them oh
yeah settle down
yeah i can't imagine you doing that i
remember being impressed too you were
like don't push
each other near the fire push each other
over there
dude his kids are going crazy they're
bonkers in bed they're bouncing all over
the place and he's like
not even like phased and he goes dude
it's like they're wasted there's little
mini wasted yeah they're like
they're like wasting people it's like
hanging out at steve's apartment back in
the day well it's crazy
it's crazy holds holds your son the
youngest
uh five he's dropping in on the skate
right he rips the ramp up yeah we got a
little mini ramp
and he's five years old yeah he was like
you want to see me get up there and do
it and he got up there
and then he just drops in on my grind
what the [ __ ] you
he kind of sometimes like pops a little
fakie ollie pop to disasters and stuff
too
he's right he's trying to do blunts he
can set up into a blunt i'm like that's
you're not ready for that but
he could do the whole thing sets up and
then it doesn't come back with him
that's funny
can't only get back in but i think
you're a great dad i think that i think
that you're like
a healthy well-adjusted person oh no you
just see the outside you don't see
wow but i think where you're coming up
short is that
you're not selling merch online
we can help you with that that's
literally what we're doing you haven't
told me that before
i don't know that's why we're here dave
you're just such a go-getter man like i
don't know i don't know anyone like you
yeah
it won't work for me i just don't have i
don't have the pizzazz i don't have the
i don't know i don't know that i have
any pizzazz or charm but but i
definitely have
i've got some [ __ ] crazy persistence
i am
a tireless [ __ ] a tireless attention
[ __ ]
and and and i got that going for me but
yeah dude you don't have to emulate
anything i'm doing i'm
like going forward and making all this
merch and stuff i just like i mean like
we've done
little jackass tours and i made some
t-shirts and stuff yeah i love your dave
england shirt i'll wear it
but i never really sold enough to make
any money like i don't think i've ever
made money selling any t-shirts ever
i've lost money selling t-shirts with a
shirt and then just give them away and
stuff
what was it on the candidate tour and
then some bet some box of wee man's
boxes
oh yeah because me and aaron got in a
fight aaron i kept
[ __ ] with aaron finally he had enough
and he punched me with his dumb rocker
rings
and like cut my head and like i dove
over the table of merch and all the
merch went everywhere and then
and all the mayhem someone else grabbed
a box of wee man's merch and
and took off with it but we got it back
do you have that footage of you and
aaron fighting
dimitri and you know actually that
reminds me what i wanted to ask you was
i know every now and then like something
that didn't air on jackass or something
you'll get it from them
but there was only one only one there
was only one a few different times no no
there's only one case i wonder how you
do that because there's so much stuff i
want to have i'm like
i would love to just be able to be like
can you go grab me this footage from
like whatever i mean i do i think that
it's
you know the one thing was when bam
broke my nose
and uh yeah i was there for that yeah
how did you get
your shot with the bb gun i was i think
i just said to tremaine i was like hey
dude i got my [ __ ] nose broken yeah i
got a [ __ ]
bb in my [ __ ] nipple and i'd for
nothing and like
let me just [ __ ] get it so i could
[ __ ] find a home for it
and tremaine was just a bro but you've
never got other footage i thought they
were yeah
i thought what footage would you want to
get dave i just random stuff like i'd
make a little list be like huh
yeah it's not that i got footage that's
the only jackass footage that i ever got
um and and other than that i just film a
lot
yeah you just have so much footage yeah
can you it was a weird skit i just
thought of it and chris told me he has
the footage i hope chris doesn't get mad
maybe check with him first what so like
chris
i i don't even know like that we live in
such a weird day and age i don't want to
get like
be a problem here but like so we did a
skit where we can't get more gay dads
a nerdy guy and he was like a all
leather daddy
and then we would meet up and then we
got their dad like a fake baby i think
and then like we would like think do
things like eat a piece of licorice and
then meet in the mouth start kissing
like
and then like i'd be on his lap and like
the baby being smashed between us
and stuff and dude that was some of
dave's creativity the [ __ ]
the fake baby on the bike oh yeah that
was the very first thing i ever did on
jackass with the fake baby with the bike
right
and then that gave birth to all kinds of
babies but yeah
baby on the car the [ __ ] snowboard
baby people did that but right
he did that because he got the idea from
yeah but um yeah that was like the first
thing i crashed that bike in front of
people and i that back then i had no
kids so i'm like this is hilarious and
then i had kids
i'm like man i'd be so bummed and sad
and like freaked out if i saw someone
like crush a baby
but before i had babies i didn't care
about them at all i was like that's
funny a baby slammed his face on the
ground ha ha
but you know it's not real but you know
you make other people think that like
women and stuff coming out of grocery
stores yeah yeah
i feel bad now it was funny but i
wouldn't take it back
yeah that [ __ ] was fantastic the other
thing i'm proud of is the sex bike i
made
that was your channel that was your
t-shirt yeah so i made that t-shirt but
back in the tv show i went to a thrift
store one day and they had this
like a weird like old like 50 style
exercise bike and i got in there
and i pedaled and so i had the kind when
you pedal the handlebars automatically
move
and i remember it went bang right into
my dick i'm like you know idea light
bulb comes out
so like they also had they had a wig on
a
mannequin head for sale i'm like can i
buy this and the styrofoam head they're
like yeah sure so i got that
all that ripped the seat off out front
just jam this thing on it
it just worked instantly it didn't like
actually
suck anything but it didn't really look
like you know it would
that's hey how's your litter robot
working for the cat
i think good cause i don't ever smell
cat [ __ ] yeah
yeah stevo gave me he more gave oops
sorry
shauna my wife he gave her a robot kitty
litter yeah
it looks like it looks like it's gonna
like take the cat to space yeah
but instead it just makes it like i
never smell cat [ __ ] anymore and um
i don't know thanks god dude that's
amazing
i i [ __ ] just want to want to tell
you thanks man
and dude like if there's anything else
we can
you know put the word out there about
follow dave on instagram follow oh i
hate instagram
i know i'm sorry just like social media
man i don't know man
i lost my social media boner when what
did i just like how do you guys just
keep wanting to do it after years ago
at first i had so much fun so much fun
and finally i'm like what am i doing
i think i told you one day that scott
randolph
got off social media stopped up with
instagram yeah
and you said i wish bam would get off
instagram
yeah so on that note well uh we'll let
it go but dad
dude thank you dave and uh at first i'm
like what's he thanking me for it
oh it's because it's the end well yeah
that's cool yeah
i'm like did i do something to be
thought it's not even it's not even
appropriate
to to say on the podcast but i you know
like thanks for putting up with me i'll
just say that in general
you're welcome yeah hell yeah yeah you
guys have a date to get to tonight yeah
we gotta wait
thank you for letting me [ __ ] like
you know
impose this podcast on you you know this
is awesome thanks for having me man i'm
stoked i think it's people i like it in
here
yeah so these are hot though it's like
wearing ear muffs but other than that
that's why you're saying they're all
itchy like i can't believe you're able
to just sit
still this whole time yeah i think it
kept my mind off it a little bit yeah do
you have anything you want to promote
i'm just kidding i said i said do you
have anything you want to promote
a good guess
oh my god i love you so much love you
too stevo and i love youtube
yeah love you too not her i don't love
this
fleabag right here she's the best go
back to peru wendy
yeah so let's go hang out with our
ladies it's the hardest i've ever
laughed man i hope everybody laughed as
hard as we did on that one
and uh if you didn't then there's
something wrong with you man because
that was hilarious
and you know dude somebody said to me
the other day
uh for the first time like hey dude do
you have your
[ __ ] raycons in your pocket and i was
like [ __ ] yeah i do
pal don't know
[Laughter]
[ __ ] but i did and uh
you know so cool man the guy said i'm
street team and i was like brother
um so yeah it just meant a lot to me and
as you all do
and of course as always man thank you
for watching have a great day
so